but I'm sure Brett entrepreneur and by  my definition that means somebody who  likes losing meaning I think of myself  much more as a UFC fighter than I think  of a buck as a boxer I like boxing more  even though that's not a popular thing  to say but but I also think that a  boxing when you get a loss it's like a  Scarlet Letter right and UFC everybody  has losses that's just like part of the  game and I've sociate to that sport more  as an entrepreneur like there is no  great entrepreneur that doesn't have  losses it's not even the cliches [ __ ] of  like you learn from your losses [ __ ]  that it's just that it meant that you  didn't take chances I'm not here to be  like you learned from your losses I'm  here like oh you have no losses getting  taken at risk which means you're on  defense or you're in passive mode which  is even scarier you're in the middle and  almost what should rather be defense  than being stuck in the middle  [Music]